يستعين بابيات السياب واقول الشمس صارت
اجمل هنا بعد ان ضم الخليج بعضه لحضني بعض
وسعاده العراقيين اشربت من ظلام انتظار
طويل وخجل وانطلقت اخيرا بطوله كاس الخليج
بدورتها الخامسه والعشرين بعد تاجيل استمر
لاربع دورات سابقه الحدث لم يكن رياضيا
فقط الحدث كان اجتماعيا وسياسيا ايضا
وتضمن قصص طلوع اللقاء جاء بعض طول فراق
يا مرحبا اهلا بكم هلا هلا هلا
نورتوا ديرتكم هلا بالناس الطيبه هلا هلا
هلا
النور شو عادت مغنيه فوق شط العرب وكان
العوده اصابت كل شيء في العراق حتى
اسكانهم على اختلافهم لنجد ايزيديه بعشيقه
وابناء الموصل وشبا ميسانيا مولعا بعروض
كره القدم كلهم جاءوا داعمين للفرحه
واخويا ومجموعه من الاصدقاء المسافه
عدوانيه اجلنا نحنا للبصره تقدم البطوله
البطوله الخليج 25
المحاوله اولى هي تقدر فعاليات اداره
القدم والمحاوله الثانيه شنو استعراض
استعراض في الشوارع
العراق العراق
التفح باعلام زائريه وبث في نفوسهم السلام
والطمانينه
وكل الشرف من الدول العربيه كلها بس العشق
السلطنه عمان احب سلطنه عمان وتولعت اكثر
شيء بسلطنه عمان لانه دوله راقيه وحبيت
سيارات عمان ونوع السيارات اللكزس 400
معروفه عند عمان
[موسيقى]
الزائرين قبل مجيئهم زال وصاروا يفكرون
بزياره اخرى كما نرى
صفوان
نشكر في اهل البصره واهل صفوان واهل
الزبير العراق بشكل عام يعني على ضيافه
حسن الضيافه الاستقبال امانه كان استقباله
طيب اااه و سعيدين بزياره البصره
وما لقينا منهم لك الخير
25 كان اهل يقولوا لي وش يوديك للعراق
الحمد لله اول ما عديت حدود العراق تغير
من عيني كل شيء هذا حسيت بالامان حسيت
بالراحه والله
صراحه همم
عكس التوقعات عكس الكلام اللي يقولوه
الناس شفنا هنا الامان وشفنا هنا
الاجواء الحلوه انا من السعوديه
واول مره صراحه يزور البصره وزوروا اراك
بل فاجا الكثيرين قدم خلاله البلد المضيف
عرضا اختصر فيه تاريخه الكبير وحضارته
وحاضره الذي يحمل املا لم ينضب مهما توالت
الخيبات زينب المشاط صباح العربيه البصره